Привет! Этот урок — небольшое отступление от нашего привычного продуктового процесса. Да, мы
собирали всю исследовательскую базу, собирали строго в дизайн-системе наши экраны, но мы разрабатывали
полноценный продукт, полноценное приложение и требования к нему соответствующие. Помимо этого,
для любого продукта есть и его маркетинговая часть. Есть посадочные страницы, то, что предназначено для
широкого пользователя, для первого касания. И там следование такое строгое: дизайн-системе,
той же самой, что мы используем для какого-нибудь веб-приложения, ну, это явно избыточно. Тем не менее,
нужен хороший визуал, нужна какая-то преемственность стилей и здесь нам может помочь с этим Cloud Design.
В моей информационной архитектуре есть одна отдельная страница, которая называется Landing Page,
её мы сегодня и соберём в Cloud Design. Посмотрим, как это вообще работает, как всё-таки свою дизайн-систему
внутри этого сервиса собрать и что потом с этим всем делать. Итак, давай посмотрим, как в Cloud Design
попасть. Начнём с самого-самого начала. Переходим просто на Cloud и здесь через боковую панель заходим на
дизайн. Ничего особо сложного нет. Ещё мы в Cloud вернёмся, будем смотреть, где там лимиты этого сервиса.
Пока давай продолжим с Cloud Design. Что здесь вообще есть? Есть у нас 4 основных режима.
Первое - это прототипирование, то есть готовые уже сайты, страницы, приложения и так далее.
Второе - slide deck, то есть презентация к твоему продукту. From template - это из какого-то уже готового шаблона.
То есть у тебя, может быть, уже готова презентация и ты хочешь как-то её видоизменить.
Когда ты её собираешь через кнопку Share поделиться, ты можешь сделать её шаблоном и затем здесь в этом меню
переиспользовать. Посмотрим ещё, как это делается. И Other, то есть какой-то совершенно вообще
рандомный проект. Это может быть чем угодно. Когда я говорю что угодно, я буквально имею в виду
что угодно. Если сюда мы перейдём на вкладку Examples - примеры, то можем увидеть, что этот инструмент
не только для каких-нибудь Landos и презентации используется. Это ещё и может быть визуализация данных,
какие-то чисто интерактивные фрагменты кода, которые ты уже в свой продукт сможешь встроить в Prode.
Здесь вот такие интересные примеры этого. Вращающийся глобус, какой-то кастомизатор карточки.
То есть всё это собирается по промпту и это, по сути, полноценные живые какие-то веб-приложения.
Также можно тестить, можно здесь тестировать какие-то стилистики.
Здесь видишь, как здесь текст, например, форматируется. Metal, ветер, снег и так далее.
Также можно лодеры создавать. И, как видишь, везде здесь достаточно короткие промпты, на самом деле.
Он очень многое додумает и делает это круто.
В целом, да, не все решения здесь по визуалу какие-то уникальные и прям хоть сейчас вставляй.
Но, тем не менее, собирает он их очень качественно и по очень короткому промпту.
Если мы более точно будем ему задавать, что мы хотим видеть, то будет вообще классно.
Вот даже калькулятор здесь можно собрать.
Здесь все эти промпты отражены.
Можно нажать "use this prompt" и точно такое же сгенерировать, в дальнейшем уже доработать.
Ну, это просто как визуализация того, что можно делать в Cloud Design.
Сразу скажу, вопреки очень частому заявлению в интернете с возникновением этого Cloud Design,
это не замена фигмы.
Ты не можешь здесь полноценно работать как в фигме.
Это инструмент быстрого прототипирования,
какой-то, возможно, итеративной визуализации,
создание каких-то кодовых сложных компонентов,
которые ты хочешь видеть на своем сайте.
И, возможно, создание там MVP отдельных кусков ТВО проекта.
Но это точно не замена фигмы.
Это не инструмент, в котором можно делать вообще все, как минимум.
Потому что тут просто нет таких возможностей.
И, как максимум, ты ограничен очень сильно лимитами.
Этот сервис еще не скоро войдет в обиход современного дизайнера.
И, в том числе, поэтому из ограничений лимитов.
Но уже сейчас она произвела большой хайп.
Огромное количество людей хотят попользоваться, посмотреть,
попробовать, что вообще получится с ней сгенерить.
И из-за этого наплыв трафика огромный.
Соответственно, сейчас лимиты достаточно строгие.
Это будет еще долго, но о них мы чуть подробнее позже поговорим.
Итак, здесь на вкладке прототипирование,
в принципе, то, для чего нам конкретно нужно сейчас этот Cloud Design,
у нас есть два варианта.
Это Warframe либо High Fidelity.
Просто набросок, либо высоко детализированный прототип.
Ну, по сути, уже финальная версия.
Так или иначе, мы используем дизайн-систему.
Мы хотим, чтобы этот лендинг, он соответствовал тому, что мы уже создали у себя в Figma.
Соответственно, нам нужно здесь создать дизайн-систему.
Делается это тут, на вкладке Design Systems.
Можешь здесь по этому уведомлению перейти.
И тут можно нажать Create.
Собираем нашу дизайн-систему.
Что вообще нам предлагает Cloud?
Первое, что мы можем заполнить, это краткое описание того, для чего мы используем эту дизайн-систему.
Какое название компании, чем мы занимаемся, какое назначение вообще у нашего продукта.
Это будет полезно в качестве такого небольшого дополнения ко всем промптам,
которые мы будем ему в дальнейшем задавать.
Если мы используем эту дизайн-систему, он уже знает, это для моего крипто VPS-сервиса.
Буквально на дизайн-системе это особо не отразится,
но на его понимании того, как строить по этой дизайн-системе то, что я от него прошу.
Но это расширит его понимание продукта.
Каждый раз, когда я буду выбирать эту дизайн-систему, он будет понимать,
что даже если я прошу просто LANDOS с этими цветами дизайн-системы,
я имею в виду, что это LANDOS для крипто VPS-сервиса.
И поскольку мы работаем в этой среде, в ней есть все,
все наши компоненты, их назначение, описание,
кто мы, чем мы занимаемся, почему мы это делаем и так далее.
Ты это все уже слышал.
Мы можем просто у агента запросить этот системный промпт описание нашего продукта.
Дай мне описание моего продукта вообще, чем мы занимаемся,
что за крипто VPS, буквально в 2-3 предложения.
Все, пускай над этим думает Клод, он нам все максимально быстро расписал.
Копируем это описание и возвращаемся в Клод дизайн.
Вообще этот шаг не то, чтобы обязательный, но лишним он точно не будет.
Следующее, что можно сюда добавить, это ссылка на гитхаб.
Смотри, у нас прототипирование, создание своего проекта,
его компонентов именно в коде для прода будет в последнем модуле, в четвертом.
Сейчас у нас этого нет, соответственно сюда нам добавить нечего.
Но в целом ты уже, наверное, знаешь, что такое гитхаб.
Если не знаешь, то это такая глобальная библиотека,
куда разрабы катят свои приложения, свой код, свои проекты и так далее,
чтобы чужие проекты себе копировать.
И здесь как раз таки он нам предлагает закинуть ссылку на гитхаб,
в котором будут уже все готовые компоненты этой дизайн-системы,
и он сможет их подтянуть и на основе их пересобрать то, что будет делать тут.
Также, возможно, твой проект не загружен на гитхаб, он у тебя хранится локально,
как это будет в четвертом модуле опять же.
И здесь также ты можешь эту папку своих компонентов сюда перетянуть, загрузив с компьютера.
Но мы простые дизайнеры, у нас есть Figma, в которой уже есть foundation,
есть дизайн-система, есть компоненты и так далее.
Все это мы сюда и загрузим.
Что нам для этого нужно?
Нам нужно перейти в Figma, открыть наш проект.
Здесь нажать на логотип Figma, файл, save local copy.
Копируем локальную копию файла.
У нас сохраняется файл с расширением FIG.
Назову его myds.
Сохраню в загрузке, возвращаюсь в Cloud Design и сюда просто либо перетягиваем,
либо выбираем этот файлик, вот myds.fig.
И смотри, здесь есть одна тонкость.
Сразу по умолчанию он предлагает все шесть страниц этого Figma файла.
Там суммарно 154 фрейма.
Вместе с ними все это закинуть.
Это, конечно, избыточно.
У нас есть конкретные страницы, предназначенные под дизайн-систему.
Именно это нам и нужно.
Если бы мы, например, загружали сразу все, то вот, например, у меня есть страница sitemap.
Эти блоки, эти фреймы и прочее, они не исполнены в нашей дизайн-системе.
Соответственно, если мы их в качестве примера сюда загрузим, то это создаст ложный контекст,
ложное понимание того, какой визуал у нас используется в нашей дизайн-системе.
То же самое можно сказать, например, про экраны.
Здесь у меня есть экраны первой версии, нулевой версии, которые сильно от идеала, от конечного результата далеки.
Ну и то же самое с варфреймами.
Он может воспринять это как уже готовые макеты.
У нас там все черно-белое будет.
Нам это точно не нужно.
У нас есть конкретные страницы, которые называются Foundation и Components.
Sitemap я отсюда убираю.
И здесь внутри Foundation также ты можешь конкретные какие-то выбрать объекты,
которые нужно перенести, на которые нужно опираться при формировании этой дизайн-системы.
Сразу скажу, он не переносит твою дизайн-систему.
Он полностью ее анализирует и как бы воссоздает уже на своем языке.
Поэтому небольшие расхождения будут, но мы еще посмотрим, как это работает.
Все, нажали attach file, прикрепили нашу дизайн-систему.
И здесь дополнительно еще какие-то данные можно добавить.
Смотри, я на самом деле под запись делаю это второй раз.
И у Клода, когда ты используешь русский язык в качестве системного промпта,
иногда возникают проблемы.
В прошлый раз у меня возникла проблема.
У меня почему-то дизайн-система не генерировалась.
Поэтому давай на всякий случай здесь еще переведем все на английский язык.
Я делаю это с расширением DPL.
Просто заменю в поле ввода.
Все, на всякий случай, чтобы точно исключить возможные причины возникновения проблемы,
если эта проблема возникнет.
И также у нас в конце есть any other notes, какие-то дополнительные сведения.
Здесь в качестве примера у нас краткое описание облика этой дизайн-системы.
Давай, в принципе, его запросим точно так же у Клода.
Отдай мне очень краткое описание моей дизайн-системы
именно по палитре, скруглениям и прочему тому, что касается визуала.
Также 2-3 предложения.
Вот он нам составил это описание, скопируем его.
Можно его попросить перевести, можно сделать это здесь уже внутри,
либо через любой другой переводчик.
Я использую расширение, которое называется DPL.
Все.
Есть у нас описание нашей платформы, есть дополнительное описание,
есть наша дизайн-система, загруженная из фильмы,
ровно с теми страницами, которые тут нужны.
Также можно загрузить логотипы, ассеты, шрифты.
У нас всего этого пока нет, поэтому на этом этапе мы двигаемся дальше.
Нажимаем Continue to Generation.
Он нас предупреждает, что это займет примерно 5 минут.
И начинаем генерацию именно дизайн-системы.
Еще не лендинга, а только этой самой дизайн-системы.
Обязательно вкладочку оставляем открытой, если куда-то хотим уходить с этой вкладки, с этой страницы.
Здесь видим, что он также себе создает SkillMD, Readme, собирает UIKit, анализирует все, что у него есть и так далее.
То есть идет преимущественно по агентскому процессу.
Только с какими-то небольшими своими собственными вводными, которые Клод от нас скрывает.
Поэтому Клод дизайн у себя просто в среде агентской воссоздать не получится пока.
Пока он читает нашу фигму, все эти файлы, давай разберемся с лимитами.
Где за ними следить, где они находятся и какие они вообще по объему.
Переходим на Клод.
Здесь заходим в настройки в нижнем левом углу.
Открываем Settings и тут у нас есть вкладка Usage.
Смотри, здесь ты можешь заметить, что лимиты Клод дизайна у нас вынесены отдельно.
Что главное здесь нужно знать?
Во-первых, лимиты у нас достаточно ограничены, но для того, чтобы попробовать собрать первую рацию, вполне их хватает.
Выдаются лимиты каждую неделю.
Соответственно, если ты в первый день их истратил полностью, тебе нужно целую неделю подождать, чтобы продолжить работу над своим проектом.
Поэтому тратим с умом.
И какого-то конкретного объема здесь не указано, но я в Клод дизайн собрал три лендинг страницы и только тогда у меня лимиты закончились.
Собрались они достаточно качественно.
Это можно было уже полностью использовать с первого раза.
Плюс еще я в нем две дизайн системы собрал перед этим.
Соответственно, лимиты достаточно большие.
В нашем случае для генерации одной лендинг страницы с дизайн системой нам их точно хватит, а то и на три вариации.
Поэтому за это можно не переживать.
Но в качестве постоянного инструмента для работы он не подходит.
Потому что ты можешь оказаться в той ситуации, когда тебе еще несколько дней нужно ждать, чтобы продолжить работу над проектом.
Также пока он генерирует, пока он рассматривает вообще все эти файлы, давай еще ознакомимся с нашим интерфейсом.
Что тут еще есть?
Во-первых, тут есть вкладка комменты.
Тут можно оставлять фидбэк о проекте, что-то запоминать, записывать, потом разом передавать агенту, чтобы он все эти правки вносил.
Именно Anthropic разработчиками Клода это задумано как такое пространство для совместной работы команды над проектом.
Но пока, конечно, от реальности это далеко и такого не предвидится.
Что у нас есть на панели чатов?
Тут у нас есть настройки.
Здесь можем выбирать какую модель использовать.
Обязательно используем самую последнюю, самую актуальную модель для каких-то фундаментальных изменений, для создания дизайн системы, для первой итерации создания проекта.
То есть, когда мы с нуля начинаем работу, возможно, используя только дизайн-систему и prompt.
И впоследствии, когда нам уже нужно какие-то текста поменять, может быть, размеры, цвета и прочее.
Ну вот, внести точечные правки.
Можно использовать модели уже попроще, чтобы лимиты так быстро не сгорали.
Также сюда мы можем прикреплять файлы, использовать голосовой режим, надиктовывать, что мы хотим изменить.
Но, сразу говорю, это хорошо работает только на английском.
И импортировать конкретные артефакты.
Опять же, тот же самый GitHub, какой-то веб-элемент, целая страничка.
Закинуть туда целую папку со своего компьютера.
Скиллы, дизайн-системы, которые уже у тебя созданы на этой платформе.
И использовать другой проект в качестве референса.
Ну, нам сейчас это все не нужно.
Также у нашего проекта есть, ну, полноценная папка со всеми вот этими артефактами.
Переходим в Design Files.
Здесь верхняя вкладка.
И тут у нас шрифты, ассеты, UI kit.
Вот все эти элементы, все эти стили.
Все, что здесь создается, тут описано в качестве вот таких HTML элементов.
Наши кнопки, наши теги и так далее.
Все то, что мы сюда загружали с помощью Figma.
После того, как он на 90% с нашей дизайн-системой разобрался,
создал уже несколько ее артефактов,
он нам предлагает пройтись по всему и проверить, что он все правильно интерпретировал,
правильно собрал.
Выглядит это так.
Вот.
Он отдельно выносит Nits Review элементы, то, что нужно проверить.
Вот здесь он собрал нашу палитру акцентных цветов и спрашивает,
классно, либо нет.
Ну, меня в целом все устраивает, поэтому я нажимаю Looks Good.
Дальше.
Оттенки серого.
Я не буду каждый hex код проверять.
Можно, на самом деле, сделать скрин и попросить агента это проверить.
Ну, такая доскональная точность мне сейчас ни к чему, поэтому просто нажимаем Looks Good.
В целом, выглядит все правдоподобно.
Эти цвета вроде бы тоже такие же.
Семантические токены тоже верно внесены.
Цвета, размеры текста, все это я сейчас просто применяю.
Вот тут уже начинаются расхождения.
Он, например, сюда добавил дополнительный шрифт.
У меня в проекте нигде его нет.
У меня все собрано на Интере.
Для лендинга это вообще вполне простительно, поэтому я нажму Looks Good,
но обращаю внимание на то, что он может вносить что-то свое.
То, что ему логически кажется правильным.
Также все наши спейсинги тоже он сюда перенес.
Радиусы скругления.
Благодаря тому, что у нас изначально все грамотно, правильно описано,
то и здесь особых расхождений, каких-то проблем я совершенно не вижу.
Когда дизайн-система менее подробно описана, не так качественно,
то тут, конечно, на самом деле расхождений возникает достаточно.
Также здесь он, например, создал новую карточку.
У меня в этой карточке тега по умолчанию нет.
И при ховере он это свойство унаследовал,
а при статичном, обычном состоянии почему-то нет.
Здесь давай поставим нет сворк и напишем ему коммент.
При ховере тег не должен исчезать.
То есть, ну вообще здесь он пишет, что hover state surface alt,
то есть альтернативное состояние поверхности этой карточки.
Возможно, он понимает, что не нужно этот тег убирать,
но рисковать я не хочу, поэтому на всякий случай для него это отмечу.
Дальше у нас еще одна карточка.
В общем, таким образом все вот эти вот точки синие закрываем,
смотрим каждый из элементов и двигаемся дальше.
Даже в качестве бонуса собрал нам вариацию нашего дашборда.
Можно здесь на него посмотреть.
Работают.
Остановлено.
Он уже интерактивный.
С ним уже можно взаимодействовать.
Что-то здесь переключается.
Ну, дроп-дауны не работают.
Input есть.
Кстати, даже поиск работает.
Например, напишу 03.
Да, он находит.
Обновить не работает.
Создать сервер.
О, даже целый конфигуратор он сразу собрал.
Выбираем образ.
План.
Все это здесь есть.
Ну, это расходится с тем, что у нас на данный момент уже собрано.
Тем не менее, на самом деле, собрал он достаточно правдоподобно.
Очень похоже, потому что мы придерживаемся одной конкретной дизайн-системы.
Все.
Я проставил, что везде у нас looks good.
Мы все посмотрели, поправили то, что было необходимо.
Наша дизайн-система готова.
Она опубликована.
И теперь, с ее помощью, мы можем создавать новый дизайн.
Здесь, в качестве дизайн-системы, он автоматически наш CryptoVPS выбрал.
Создадим новый проект, который будет называться Landing Page.
Итак, у нас дизайн-система уже выбрана.
Сюда он также предлагает закинуть какие-то скриншоты, кодовую базу,
перетащить Figma-файл.
В общем, все то, что на самом деле у нас уже проставлено.
Поэтому это для нас не релевантно.
Итак, здесь он нам предлагает описать, что мы вообще хотим создать.
Для того, чтобы долго не думать, давай у нашего агента запросим,
все это описание лендинга.
У нас в нашей информационной архитектуре предусмотрена страница лендинга.
Придумай для нее структуру, ее описание.
То есть, ну, создай полный ТЗ по ее именно наполнению,
по описанию того, что на ней должно быть, в какой последовательности и так далее.
Обязательно исходи из всех наших исследований и общего контекста среды.
Итак, он дал подробное, полное описание того, что нам нужно.
На самом деле даже, я бы сказал, избыточное описание.
И чтобы это все не копировать и не терять формат всех этих данных,
потому что, ну, там таблицы, например, плохо перенесутся.
Давай попросим его оформить это в качестве МД-файлика.
И пока он его генерирует, сразу отмечу.
Этот инструмент, Cloud Design, достаточно креативный.
Как и все креативные инструменты, он сильно отходит от твоего ТЗ,
для того, чтобы предоставить какой-то визуал получше.
Поэтому имей в виду, что всему этому описанию,
каким бы подробным оно не было, он не будет соответствовать на 100%.
Это важно помнить.
Так или иначе, вот конечный артефакт, то, что он создаст, мы экспортируем,
перекинем сюда в свой проект и здесь уже отдельно будем дорабатывать.
Поэтому даже если где-то структурно, фактологически,
у нас что-то будет хромать в том лендинге, который он создаст,
здесь уже внутри Cloud Code мы сможем это все поправить.
Итак, ТЗ у нас есть, Landing Spec.
Посмотрим, найдем его в Finder и просто перетянем в наш проект.
Посмотрю, где он находится у меня, в какой папке.
И просто перетяну в рабочее окно Cloud Design.
Сюда закинем.
Файл прикрепился.
Ну и, наверное, пишем:
"Вот по этому файлу Landing Spec.md.
Создаем мне лендинг-страницу".
Все, отправляем ему наше требование и ждем.
Подождать придется прилично, минут 10-15.
Итак, он собрал первый вариант нашего лендинга.
Тут, что мы видим сразу?
У нас переключение между версиями английской и русской.
Видимо, это было заложено в качестве promptа.
Ну, это и логично, учитывая специфику сервиса.
Но, например, он тут не полностью переводится.
Ну ладно, это нормально.
Я бы не хотел, чтобы он тратил лимиты просто на то,
чтобы всю страницу еще перевести на другой язык.
Что у нас здесь есть аккуратное окошко с визуализацией, там, какой-то максимально базовой нашей платформы.
Все кнопочки в нашей дизайн-системе, все выглядит консистентно по отношению к тому, что у нас сейчас в Figma.
Наш логотип очень похожий на в бар.
Возможность войти, создать аккаунт.
Что у нас еще есть?
Четыре отличия.
Ну, достаточно базовое сделано.
Тут немного есть небольшой косяк с иконкой.
Но, в целом, абсолютно нормально.
Для специфики сервиса вполне.
От регистрации до сервера четыре шага.
Здесь, опять же, обратите внимание, что у нас, вот, например, четыре отличия.
У нас этот блок здесь появился не просто так.
У нас все исходит из наших исследований, из нашей дизайн-системы, из нашей среды, в которой все это описано.
Соответственно, это заложено было в prompt, это заложено в дизайн-систему и в общую направленность платформы.
Мы вообще дали все данные, которые только нужны для того, чтобы у нас получился хороший, релевантный результат, который действительно более потребителя потенциального отрабатывает.
Описаны четыре шага, что конкретно нужно сделать.
Вот, например, также одна из более, которую я нашел.
Что недостаточно прозрачный формат оплаты, аренды этого сервиса.
Здесь также это блоком отработано.
Еще и с такой микроинтеракцией, с визуализацией всего этого дела.
Выглядит круто.
Также блок цен, с теми ценами, которые нам предложил агент.
Тут у нас характеристики этих устройств, которые предлагаются.
Возможность выбрать тот или иной тариф.
Все максимально аккуратно, чисто, просто, именно в нашей дизайн-системе собрано.
Какие мы предоставляем сервера?
В Figma у меня ровно те же самые.
BIS QIC - это позиция, а не лазейка.
Выведен статус, который говорит о том, что у нас стабильно работают сервера.
Отдельно какие-то числа, параметры и так далее.
И есть часто задаваемые вопросы, которые точно так же он сам понял, какие могут возникать.
И на свое усмотрение их закрыл и расписал.
Здесь это тоже очень удобно.
Ну и в конце CTA готовы поднять первый сервер.
Регистрация по e-mail без верификации.
Да, ну в общем все то, что нашей платформе соответствует.
Выглядит супер чисто, аккуратно, структурно то, что нам нужно.
Теперь, какие у нас еще есть возможности работы со всем этим делом?
У нас тут есть такой функционал как Twix.
Это какие-то дополнительные виджеты, вариации твоих блоков.
Возможность визуализировать какой-то альтернативный вариант того, что уже есть.
Вот, например, у меня есть блок.
Как это работает?
От регистрации до сервера.
Четыре конкретных шага.
И мне кажется, его можно как-то интереснее визуализировать, показать именно этапность, сколько это занимает.
И через Twix я как раз могу попросить его это сделать.
Также, если ты нажмешь здесь Ideas, он сам найдет такие вот узкие места, которые можно как-то иначе интерпретировать, визуализировать и предложит тебе это сделать.
Я уже нажал эту кнопку, он запустил процесс, начал искать.
Параллельно с этим давай также попрошу его поработать над блоком, как это работает.
Я хочу поработать над блоком, как это работает.
Добавить какой-то вариант с более интересной визуализацией, именно этапности.
Чтобы это было интересно, возможно, анимировано и прозрачнее давало понять, как этот процесс выглядит, из чего состоит и сколько занимает по времени.
Он уже с первыми нашими правками закончил, когда я нажимал Ideas.
И здесь можем нажать Reload для того, чтобы посмотреть на актуальную версию.
Так, он сказал, что Hero секцию поправил, но, честно говоря, никаких изменений не вижу.
Возможно, нужно полностью обновить страницу.
Сделаю это уже после того, как он с этим процессом закончит, чтобы его не срывать.
Также, помимо этого, здесь можно оставлять комменты.
Этот функционал соотносится с тем, что у нас на этой вкладке с комментами.
Все, что мы сейчас пометим в качестве комментов, будет сюда добавлено.
Также в этом режиме мы можем выбирать конкретные объекты, которые хотим поправить.
Вот, например, изменить что-нибудь в этом тексте, объяснить, в чем проблема.
И затем отправить сразу в код, чтобы он этот комментарий принял во внимание.
Также есть достаточно ограниченный Edit функционал.
То есть, есть у нас, например, текст.
Мы хотим этот текст сократить, изменить его цвет, непрозрачность, какие-то отступы.
Самые базовые настройки здесь мы можем вносить.
Но, имей в виду, что после того, как ты их внесешь, они не сразу в код запишутся.
Ему нужно будет еще все это дело обработать.
И это тоже потратит лимиты.
Несмотря на то, что это все-таки максимально простые будут правки.
Итак, он изменил уже вот этот вот формат этапности.
Мы можем увидеть здесь, что он все это визуализирует, смотрит, проигрывает, действительно ли оно работает.
Проводит этап верификации, прежде чем нам финальный результат отдать.
Ну, пока не будем в это вмешиваться.
Пускай он проводит верификацию.
Мы видим, что там, на самом деле, достаточно много различных этапов.
Много чего происходит.
Все. Раздел, как это работает, обновлен.
Появилась анимированная сцена.
Давай не будем медлить и посмотрим, что же такого он создал.
Итак, когда мы создаем твики, у нас появляется дополнительный виджет,
который позволяет вот эту альтернативную визуализацию настраивать.
Давай посмотрим, как сейчас это работает.
У нас автоматически анимируется этот этап.
Проходим регистрацию, пополнение, сканирование QR-кода.
Здесь, ну, достаточно корявенько, да, вот это заполнение сделано.
У нас сместились вот эти этапы.
Они не поровну распределены.
Но, тем не менее, выглядит уже интересно.
И визуализация достаточно крутая.
Немного ее докрутить через Cloud Code и уже хоть сейчас дропой.
Также, если нам не понравилось, можем вернуть нашу сетку, оставить так.
Но, я думаю, конечно, таймлайн значительно круче.
Также, что у нас еще есть?
У нас твики добавлены в HeroBlock.
Мы можем выбрать здесь скриншот панели, прогноз баланса.
То есть, альтернативные визуализации, которые сюда можно добавить.
Вот это, кстати, классно выглядит.
Но это может создавать ошибочное впечатление, что у нас все через терминал будет работать.
А это противоречит запросам наших потенциальных пользователей.
У нас там было расписано, что будет круто, если через Telegram все это можно будет делать.
Поэтому нам это не совсем подходит.
Прогноз баланса, скриншот панели.
Ну, в общем, мне, на самом деле, первый вариант больше всего нравится.
Поэтому оставлю его.
Также для Hero-секции у нас можно поменять тон.
Поставить тут.
Сделать, чтобы заголовок немного другой был.
Но это, конечно, никуда не годится.
Также в таком терминальном стиле с шрифтом.
Это мне точно не подходит.
На самом деле, кстати, весь сайт меняется, а не только Hero.
Нет, это точно не то.
И какие-то альтернативные варианты палитры.
Но у нас достаточно строго это задано.
Поэтому тут ничего не меняется.
Так, после того, как мы настроили, чтобы эта штука не мешала,
твики можно отключить.
И мы возвращаемся к исходнику.
Вот.
Теперь можно тут его еще помучить.
Вот эту штуку попросить его выровнять.
Сделать, чтобы дольше эти этапы проходили и так далее.
Короче, еще долго над этим всем можно работать.
Но я думаю, что нам на этом этапе полностью достаточно того, что мы имеем.
Если мы уже хотим эту итерацию показать, не знаю, например, клиенту,
можем выбрать NewTap.
У нас этот сайт загрузится.
Как правило, загружается он не с первого раза, но вот сейчас у меня сразу загрузился.
Если не загружается, просто обнови пару раз, все обязательно загрузится.
И это уже, ну, полноценная лайв-страница, с которой можно взаимодействовать.
Все у нас здесь интерактивное.
Все работает.
Все выглядит круто.
Здесь эти вкладки переключаются.
Тарифы есть.
Сервера все описаны.
Приватность.
FIQ.
Все работает.
Вот, по сути, готовая лендинг-страница к моему продукту.
Я ее могу теперь докрутить еще Figma или сразу перекинуть в нашего агента.
Для того, чтобы он ее внедрил в уже существующий продукт.
Но продукта и его прототипа у нас пока нет, потому что мы не на четвертом модуле.
Ограничимся переносом всего этого дела Figma и внесем, ну, какие-нибудь правки.
Это значит, что нам пора переходить к вкладке Share.
И что мы здесь можем сделать?
Во-первых, мы можем скопировать ссылку и раздать доступ для членов своей команды.
Что-то здесь допиливать, менять, работать дальше над проектом.
Все это можно делать совместно.
Пока я, честно говоря, не представляю workflow, в котором это возможно,
учитывая такие ограничения по лимитам.
Но, тем не менее, функционал такой есть.
Далее, можем дублировать проект, чтобы продолжить отдельно над ним работу.
Создать какую-то другую его итерацию.
Скопировать его в качестве шаблона.
Ну, тем самым уже шаблон создать.
Скачать проект как zip.
Вот тут у нас, например, есть дизайн файлы с этой страницы.
У нас все на конкретном фреймворке уже собрано.
И эти все файлы мы можем скачать и там захостить, например, где-то у себя вот эту страничку.
Также экспортировать как pdf, как презентацию pptx.
Но это если ты здесь презентации создаешь.
Отправить в канву.
Не знаю, у кого такие специфичные интересы.
Также можно экспортировать как отдельный html файлик и передать в код код.
Смотри, логичнее всего здесь кажется передать в код код.
Казалось бы, мы в нем и работаем.
Но работает здесь это не всегда.
Поэтому, если у тебя не получается передать в код код,
ты просто нажимаешь export as standalone html
и перекидываешь все это дело себе в папку с твоей средой.
Ну, давай посмотрим, как это работает.
Если они это пофиксили, то сейчас у нас получится все это дело перенести.
Скопируем и вернемся к агенту.
Я им напишу.
Я сгенерировал, создал эту лендинг страницу.
Вот она.
Да, в этот раз все работает.
Он полностью видит этот архив, скачивает его.
Поэтому проблем тут никаких не возникнет.
Смотри, пока все это он скачивает, рассматривает, работает с этими файлами.
Давай посмотрим альтернативный путь без использования код код.
Возвращаемся в код дизайн.
Нажимаем share.
Нажимаем export as standalone html.
Он думает, пересобирает весь наш проект для того, чтобы это был один отдельный html файл, который можно сразу вставлять.
Пока он это делает, в Figma тебе нужно найти плагин, который называется html2design.
Запускаем его и он html страницы сюда переносит в наш документ.
Здесь у нас наша html страничка создалась.
Мы можем ее скачать.
Она сохранилась.
Теперь мы можем перейти в Figma и сюда в качестве файла этот документ загрузить.
Он нам предлагает использовать auto layout, создать стили и переменные, или использовать локальные стили.
Сразу скажу, всего этого лучше не делать, чтобы у тебя всю твою дизайн систему этот перенос не разрушил.
Это, напомню, альтернативный вариант и его недостаток в том, что мы не подвязываемся ни к компонентам, ни к стилям, ни к переменным, вообще совершенно ни к чему.
Он просто в тупую переносит этот файл и делает это не очень-то аккуратно.
Этот вариант тебе подходит, если ты просто создаешь какой-то landdose, хочешь здесь его поправить и потом передать его агента, чтобы он тебе сразу его сверстал, на сервер залил.
Если ты работаешь с продуктом, такой подход нам точно не подходит.
Но на всякий случай я его покажу.
Все, он перенес нашу страницу.
В основном у нас все аккуратно, все собрано на автолейаутах, но имею в виду, что вот эта вложенность, она больше свойственна именно для HTML-архитектуры и не все здесь собрано аккуратно, логично и так далее.
Поэтому это нужно будет править.
Так или иначе, здесь у нас все это дело работает, все выглядит достаточно аккуратно.
Ну, здесь он вариации эти не загрузил, разумеется, тут, конечно, да, с анимированным блоком уже сложнее.
Эта секция у нас есть и все на самом деле достаточно аккуратно собрано, этим можно уже пользоваться.
Опять же, единственный минус, ничего и нигде у нас здесь не привязано.
Мы можем сейчас попросить агента это сделать, привязать все стили и так далее, но тогда, конечно, проект может развалиться.
Так или иначе, с этим уже можно работать.
Эту версию я перенесу на новую страницу, которую я создал, она называется архив и оставлю ее здесь просто на всякий случай.
У меня есть уже страница с экранами, в ней я создам дополнительную новую секцию, которую назову лендинг.
И попрошу в этой секции агента воссоздать вот этот наш проект, который был собран в Cloud Design.
Копируем ссылку на эту секцию и возвращаемся к Клоду, который здесь уже весь проект собрал.
Смотри, через Figma MCP в этой конкретной секции мне нужно, чтобы ты эту лендинг-страницу отрисовал.
Разумеется, ты должен использовать наши компоненты, текстовые стили, токены и так далее, чтобы все в нашей дизайн-системе соответствовало.
Ты должен понимать, что это все-таки лендинг-страница, не нужно под какие-то каждые повторяющиеся элементы создавать новые компоненты и так далее.
Но то, что является базой, такие вещи, как, например, кнопки, цвета и прочее, и то, что будет логично переиспользовать, нужно переиспользовать.
Все, закидываем ему prompt и просто ждем.
Видим, что он начал с первой секции, с Header, Hero.
Посмотрим, да, здесь уже у нас все это дело собирается.
Тут с иконкой он закосячил, этот блок он закосячил.
В общем, процесс это не быстрый, но более качественный, ответственный и аккуратный.
Не буду ждать, пока он закончит.
В принципе, здесь все дальше однотипно, он будет просто воссоздавать эти экраны, потом скринить, проверять, что получилось ли у него все, вносить какие-то правки и так далее, пока какого-то приличного результата не достигнет.
Итак, если мы хотим быстро, мы просто экспортируем HTML-страницу, вставляем ее и, ну, в целом это будет выглядеть нормально, возможно, стоит только агента попросить привязать это все к переменным, каким-то компонентам и так далее.
Но это будет долго и не факт, что у тебя весь этот экран как бы сразу не развалится.
Плюс таких правок может быть много, что-то можно упустить.
В общем, процесс это точно так же займет время.
Если хотим, чтобы сразу на нашей дизайн-системе аккуратно все собиралось через подключение к лод-коду с этой ссылкой, которая нам дается в клад-дизайне и просим его пересобрать на нашей дизайн-системе.
У нас есть там разные блоки, разные визуализации.
Да, идеально сразу он все не перенесет, но это вполне нормально.
На этом все.
В качестве домашнего задания для своего проекта также создай лендинг-страницу, которая представит твой проект, опишет.
Возможно, это какая-то конкретная фича, для нее тоже может быть лендинг, описание того, почему она нужна, почему это важный апдейт в твоем продукте.
Проходишь те же этапы, которые я показывал сегодня и в конечном итоге присылаешь ссылку на твой Figma Frame с этим сайтом.
Для импортирования Figma ты можешь использовать любой способ из тех, что я сегодня показал.
Здесь уже на твое усмотрение, как тебе удобнее.
На этом все. Удачи с выполнением домашнего задания и увидимся на следующем уроке.